i know more and more people are
quietly at the moment
acknowledging that yes indeed something
is wrong
that that is leaking that is that is now
a leaky colander that's
the truth is gushing out now yes
and there's something
this has been such a
an existential
event an experience that it has come
down i mean people write me letters and
they talk about light and dark good and
evil
right and wrong it's it's been it's been
distilled down to very basic stuff now
and what i take reassurance from is that
the truth will out i mean it's a cliche
this
whether it happens today or tomorrow or
i couldn't put a time scale on it but i
know the truth will out because that's
what the truth does
it is perennial as the grass it will
re-emerge from whatever is
laid upon it to
to
uh
you to obfuscate to obliterate it'll it
will come back
so i i'm trusting that the truth will
work in our favor eventually it's become
that cut and dried for me it's become
that simple good and evil right and
wrong what's being done is wrong
and
wrong will not prevail
right will prevail
i wish i shared your confidence
i think in a prior era that might be
right but the novelty of our era makes
me wonder about it
and i believe part of what you're saying
is certain and in fact the truth has
already emerged and there are many
people who are never going back into the
cave right who have simply seen it
but
the problem is
the thing that has captured all of our
institutions and i don't pretend to know
what it is i can
say something about its dimension based
on how it behaves and what it's
obviously capable of but i don't know
what it is and i don't know what it
wants
that thing
has to be beaten it has to be defeated
because it is a reckless monster
right it is obviously capable with the
tools at its disposal of doing
tremendous harm to humanity or worse so
it has to be defeated and so the point
is the fact that the truth has emerged
that there are some of us who have
detected important elements of it and
that we are now in conversation is good
but we need enough power to marshal the
next argument and
when i began
looking at kovid
it started for me with the lab leak
right
i did not actually expect us to win that
argument all right i did expect that we
would figure out
whether it had happened and i believe we
are essentially there
but i did not expect the public to
become aware that the wet market or some
other natural origin story just didn't
fly and yet it did and at the point that
that had happened my thought was
well the lab leak was a surprise win
you've got except it was it's we won
because it was true
that's my
it's it it couldn't the truth emerges
it
does that's why the public have accepted
broadly that it was a lab leak now we
don't yet know whether there was any
intent or just accident right
that's its origin story it came out of
that building
having been tampered with you know that
and and the fact that that has emerged
and been accepted i think is is a point
on my on my school it is it is the truth
came out the truth came out and it
actually stuck right they did not manage
to muddle it enough that people don't
get it now they don't get the second
part of it right i i feel like the lone
voice saying actually
it's not even true
that
um
the fact of it having emerged may be
effectively settled but downstream of
that it's just like it had emerged
naturally
the consequences of the protocols that
it will have been run through to produce
its capabilities are fundamentally
important to the disease that it causes
and to the way it spreads and therefore
we are entitled to know how it was
created and if they will not tell us we
are entitled to put together a working
group of the best minds and reverse
engineer what must have been done so
that we can understand what this thing
is and
i can't i can't emphasize enough how
much rests on the question of what the
thing is what they were trying to
produce where they were in the process
what protocols were used what creatures
was it run through in the serial
passaging what tissues was it run
through these are critical questions
from the point of view of knowing how to
control it
so
hopefully that level will emerge at some
point but i'm not confident it will
but the
the other issues in the covid debacle
right the question of repurposed drugs
and early treatment and the question of
vaccine safety and effectiveness
were it true that the truth came out and
that the public came to understand it
the way it understands lab leak right
those three things together
then
once you've seen what happened there
tell you ah i can see the failure of
every layer of our system i can see the
failure of the journalists i can see the
role of the tech sector i can see the
failure of government i can see the
relationship between national
governments and these international
bodies i can see
the gavi the trusted news initiative all
of these elements of that failure would
be made would be laid bare
and were we to get to that moment
then the really important thing then
would have a party
well that would be that would be quite
the day it would be quite today because
that would be that would that would be
revelatory
in every sense in every
understanding of the work of the world
that would change the world
because like you and but for different
reasons i just know that there's
something profoundly wrong across the
board
institutions have been captured
something is rotten in the state of
denmark i just know that
if that becomes
generally accepted and furthermore
explained and exposed
then that would
that would rearrange the building blocks
of
of society itself
and it's it would be it's no surprise
that that's why that's not going to
happen today and it's not going to
happen tomorrow it's it's so big
i think we're i think we're on
i think part of my my
smoldering anxiety every minute of every
day
is because i'm aware that
the the the necessary
uh
sequence of events is so
profound it's a paradigm shift
a and and it's not just a paradigm shift
it's going to it's going to expose
something that has been going wrong
presumably for a very very long time and
that's going to be very difficult for
everyone for for both sides
in the war
there's no one is going to avoid
being hurt by that revelation
well i also
you know you say it will be revelatory
i think for those of us who are
aware of it it will be revelatory
because we've already grappled you know
and i think in your in your talk
yesterday you spoke about the grief
process and what role it plays in in the
discovery here those of us who have
already
gone through it
right will be
relieved that we can at least now
finally talk about the topic right wrong
at every level captured across the board
no functional institutions
for everybody else
that is going to be a terrifying moment
and it has to be i don't want them
terrified but we have to get through the
terrifying moment to get to the moment
where we get to discuss what we're going
to do about it right and to me
this isn't about covet and it was never
about covet covid reveals the problem
what i've learned though my what i the
reassurance i would offer people is that
the revolution it's difficult
but it's survivable it's yeah
it's not that bad you know the you know
the
the greatest fear is fear itself you
know you know
we have become a society for example
that is that is terrified of pain
physical pain because we have so many
means of
dealing preventing pain
anesthetics and painkillers and all the
rest of it
there's some
justification for thinking you might get
through your three score and 10 without
ever having an ouchie because pain
relief is so sophisticated so people are
terrified of pain but the you know the
reality you go back a couple hundred
years and people are having legs
amputated you know by saw doctors
and these and they actually survived it
and it and it's arguably the case that
they it hurt them less because they just
weren't as afraid of the pain yeah the
pain still hurts
but being terrified of the pain
it
exacerbates the situation i think and i
think people have we've had a 70 years
since the
you know the last great global
conflagration
and there's an illusion that you can go
through your life without suffering
but when you realize that no you can't
there will be suffering
and the suffering is survivable
that's a moment
oh it's huge that you can you think well
the worst has happened and i'm still
here
i i thought it would make me cease to
exist
i thought it would be too much for me
but it's not and
the bit of the process that i've gone
through has that's been the revelation
for me i thought well
it's okay
it's it's a rotten thing to understand
it's a rotten thing to go through but
it's
it's survivable here's the here's the
other side
well it's better than that um and i'm
going to return us to what might be the
most important topic here
i have a
lifelong fascination with plato's cave
i think the story is important i think
it keeps returning to us in modernized
forms you know the matrix is clearly
plato's cave and the matrix might
actually add an element that plato
needed and it's not there right what
happens to the person who leaves plato's
cave when he returns is
important for people to understand right
those inside the cave
don't want to know
those
out here in modernity who make the
discovery that you're talking about
i believe and i think you believe will
go through a terrifying grief process
you and i both know it's finite because
we've done it
on the other side of that not only is
there the relief of
having grappled with it and processed it
and still being functional and alive and
and all of that
but there is
a marvelous
group of people who have
gone through it too and effectively
you join that group at the point that
your eyes open and it's you know it's
like the nebuchadnezzar in in
in the matrix
so
you know i've been trying to figure out
how to convey this to people and and i
came up with this see what you think
it sucks
to be in a foxhole right it's no place
any rational person wants to find
themselves living
but the company in the foxhole is
incredible you will find the most
remarkable people in this foxhole and
you will
you're better off you will feel better
having the company of those people their
insight their calm right their sense of
humor than being stuck uh in
whatever the bunker is where it's all
lies and everybody's untrustworthy
because they're terrified they're going
to be slandered that they're going to be
accused of you know sitting down with
the wrong person or whatever the
accusations are
it's it's the captain scott thing it's
far better to die like this than in too
much comfort at home
you know and you know in shackleton you
know i'm big you know you're talking
about plato's cave and i'm one of my
sort of true norths is well ironically
shackleton's south and when you know
when
it's that when because they were doing
something that was so physically arduous
and in many respects they just wanted it
to be over
but it
it showed them something about
themselves that they would not have
achieved
in any other way
and
it's there is a there is a great there's
a profound relief
in knowing that it is worth suffering
your suffering is its own reward i'm not
you know you've got to be careful you
know we're not
we're talking about things are largely
psychological rather than rather than
physical but when you go through that
sort of i mean i've i felt as if i said
yesterday over the last couple years i
realized that the world i thought i knew
had died and i was grieving for it
and i did grieve for it but i came out
of the other side of it
all through the
you know the anger the denial the
bargaining the you know the depression
i did come through it and
you think before that process begins
that you don't ever want to have that
you don't ever want to go through it but
it's better to have gone through it
it's enriching
and it's meant that you know the
encounters that i was having yesterday
with with other people from all sorts of
walks of life and you know people i was
only going to spend these two minutes
with probably probably the only two
minutes i'm ever going to have with this
person and they were so intense
and it was all fueled by the fact that
they had gone they had come to the same
understanding in their own way and i was
standing hugging
total strangers
and you think this is worth it
which ain't happened
but it's worth it
[Music]
you